- I wanna say this too though.
So Cedric, you played Dr.
King's closest friend,
Ralph Abernathy.
- Yeah.
- In a Spike Lee movie.
So did you learn anything about Dr. King
that surprised you that maybe wasn't ever,
isn't showcased on the regular?
- Well, in this movie "Son of South"
I actually had studied the dude,
I've been cast for Ralph
Abernathy in "Selma" too.
And so, but,
what I found out the most is their,
their sense of humor.
What I really loved is
between the two of them
they were really friends
and they had this buddy
energy that I think
that you miss when someone is such a
a great history, you know,
historic figure is that you
always see them as serious.
And what I really loved is
that they were friends and buddies
and had this shorthand with
each other and laughed a lot.
And so therefore, you know, it was that
that understanding that,
how do you do a work
like that, when every
day seems so serious?
You have to have some degree of like
where life is comfortable and you,
and that was his partner.
And I like that. I loved the,
(audience clapping)
The idea that...
- Well, it's interesting to me,
- they had each other for that.
- It's interesting to
me too, though, I find
like the most deep people I
know are usually comedians,
even if they're, it's not their job.
They're the people that
make you laugh so hard.
And they have such a deep understanding,
a deep intelligence for a lot of things.
And it is, they are
the more serious people
in my life as well.
- But I think you have to
find that humor to have that,
If balance existed, but to
have that kind of balance, too,
because you wanna address
things and you wanna be a
part of things but at the same
time it can be overwhelming
and it feels so big that you
can't conquer it, you know?
So you need humor.